hey guys it's November 3rd and we're
only one day away from Blizzcon and
infinite warfare so much is happening
I'm Cassidy and I've got your news
first up prepare to have your skills
tested and call duty infinite warfare
Yolo mode infinite warfare has a few
fairly intense modes as detailed on
Activision's blog the specialist mode is
unlocked once the campaign is completed
on any difficulty it is described as
intensely realistic and not for the
faint of heart in this mode you can only
heal with nano shots as there is no
health regeneration in addition to that
helmets are your only protection from
headshots and take permanent damage
there's a whole lot more to it that'll
put you to the test check out the full
list of conditions in specialist mode on
GameSpot calm and if you manage to
complete specialist mode you'll get
access to the Yolo mode as Activision
explains this mode is unlocked after
beating the game on specialist and well
you only live once by that we mean
genuine perma death if you die you will
start all the way back at the beginning
of the entire game infinite warfare will
unlock at midnight Eastern Time on
November 4th in North America next up
take two talks about those Mafia 3
review scores and talks about more
remasters in addition to confirming that
Grand Theft Auto 5 has shipped 70
million copies take to CEO Straus
Zelnick also discussed mafia threes
review scores and remasters during an
earnings call yesterday on the subject
of mafia threes review scores Zelnick
said scores were lower than what the
company hoped for but at the same time
he remarked that the title is selling
very well noting that has shipped 4.5
million copies in its first week to set
a new record for 2k games in terms of
the reviews and scores it was sort of an
odd anomaly Zelnick explained the scores
were lower than we would have liked but
there are a lot of stellar reviews I
think the most prominent reviewers
really loved it and recognized that what
we're doing here from story art
character and excitement perspective is
really unmatched in the marketplace so I
think we and our competitors are seeing
some anomalies in the review system but
we take them as they are and we don't
argue with it
GameSpot's mafia 3 review scored the
game at a 6 out of 10 also during the
call an analyst asked Zelnick for his
thoughts on possibly releasing more
remasters is that something take 2 would
consider following the launch of
Bioshock the collection potentially yes
he replied anytime we have something
that goes well or doesn't go well it
definitely informs our decision-making
but we don't have anything specific to
announce the good news is we have a rich
trove of intellectual property and there
are definitely more things that will be
brought to the market in the future but
nothing that we would announce on
today's call and last but not least I've
got some sweet ps4 and Xbox one Black
Friday deals for you Black Friday is
coming up later this month and if you're
in the market for a new PlayStation 4 or
Xbox one you're in luck
we have ads posted the Kohl's Black
Friday ad today revealing two hundred
and fifty dollar ps4 and Xbox ones you
can get the 500 gigabyte Uncharted 4 ps4
slim model with $75 in Kohl's cash for
only two hundred and fifty dollars
additionally the store will sell the 500
gigabyte minecraft Xbox one s bundle
with the Kohl's cash for the same price
the Kohl's ad says some Black Friday
deals will be available online starting
on Monday the 21st while supplies last
physical stores open at 6:00 p.m. on
November 24th these doorbuster deals
will end by 1:00 p.m. on Black Friday
November 25th so shop early
it appears that two hundred and fifty
dollars for a new ps4 or Xbox one is the
standard console deal this year Dell may
have the deal to beat this year for Xbox
one as its offering the 500 gigabyte
battlefield 1 Xbox one s bundle with a
free copy of Gears of War and an extra
controller for 250 dollars let me know
we take of today's stories in the
comments below and don't forget that
next week we have extra life it's going
on from Friday to Sunday the 11th to
13th we're streaming games for 72 hours
and raising money for charity it's all
for the kids so check it out and donate
and I'll see you tomorrow
you